hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the speechers
championship semi-finals Maxima Sherlock
versus Magnus Carlson we've already seen
one game and this one is from the bullet
section so Magnus won the uh he won the
both Blitz sections the five plus one
and the three plus one blade sections uh
only in three plus one uh Maxime was
very very close to actually tying that
um uh time control uh but now this is
bullet it's uh it's one plus one so it's
not like it's a real bullet uh one plus
one is like infinite time for these guys
so it's uh actually a top level game
except for the part where uh Maxine
directly disrespects Magnus as he plays
a line that everyone knows is bad like
you guys know this line is bad and if
you've ever tried it you know uh you
will get completely crushed but he he
just couldn't get uh any wins I mean he
did get some wins but he just couldn't
get on uh any sort of a streak that
would enable him to tie the match so he
had to resort to this so let's uh let's
check it out Maxim has the white pieces
and he opens with E4 we have E5 by
Magnus D for now uh going for the for
the central uh Central game and if white
does not pick up the pawn then it's sort
of a central Gambit he captures on D4
and not Knight to F3 the kissersky
variation Knight to C6 and now Bishop to
C4 uh the so-called Squad Gambit we have
Knight to F6 and now Pawn to E5 and this
has been one of my favorite things to
play when uh when I first started the
learning uh openings and when I started
learning chess uh but I soon realized
that if black just plays D5 black is
perfectly fine not just perfectly fine
black is even better and that is of
course what Magnus plays now this isn't
the weird part the weird part is what
happens next
here your Bishop is attacked and best
for you to do here is just play Bishop
to B5 and this is how every top level
game goes Bishop T5 Knights the E4
Knight captures on D4 you put pressure
on C6 Bishop D7 captures captures and
then White Castles and black continues
with the developing the bishop or maybe
C5 or something like that uh so what
else could you do you could play e
captures and D6 Alpha song but then just
Bishop captures on D6 and uh it's
actually black who's up in development a
white sacrifice material but it's black
was up in development so this isn't uh
again something you want to do and of
course the pawn cannot be captured
because if you do this then you will
blunder your Queen Bishop B4 check picks
up the queen now and D4 so instead after
this D5 move we have e characters on F6
and this is the move that I was talking
about everyone knows this is bad Maxim
knows this is bad Magnus knows this is
bad but he tried everything else so he
will now try this and okay let's see
yeah I mean Magnus knows his bad but
does he really know how to punish it by
heart or will he have the soul that uh
in bullish time control the characters
on C4 of course you will win back the
piece uh castles by Maxine and now G
captures on F6 this is better than Queen
captures especially
uh in in such a quick game uh because
now Bishop to G5 Rook D1 it all looks
very very scary for black even though
it's still fine like Queen F5 You're
Gonna Play rookie one check Bishop to E6
uh you're gonna block this and
everything is okay but okay after
Castle's G captures on F6 and now Bishop
to F4 still waiting with that Rook D1
move uh as uh you know from experience
it doesn't really do all that much
Bishop to E6 and now Comes The Rook to
E1 uh interestingly we're still in known
territory the position has been reached
in the 1999 under 15 girls championship
of morava uh between uh players named
Susana borosova and Barbara zabadilova
and the game ended I have no idea how
the game ended but I will check I don't
want to trick you guys uh just give me a
second uh yeah black black won the game
but in this game uh Knight beta D2 was
not played here we have Rook to E1
finally Maxine plays this and it is not
as of move 9 that we have a completely
new game uh Queen to D7 Magnus prepares
the castle Queen side which makes sense
you have the open the semi-openg file
you want to use this for attack C3 and
now Magnus doesn't even want to advance
the pawn to D3
rather he starts by castling Queen side
uh and okay uh Magnus castled and now C
captures on D4 we have Knight captures
on D4 and now Knight to C3 you don't
really gain anything by capturing
because Magnus would very very gladly
trade Queens here he's up to pawn so any
trade that goes uh his way so Knight to
C3 we have rooked the G8 by Magnus and
now Bishop to G3 closing of the G file
and now it seems like you might be
actually in business but it it all
really depends and Magnus should
continue with something like Knight to
F5 or C5 or F5 but he plays Pawn the H5
and he gives Maxim this tiny bit of Hope
of re-entering the game but Maxim misses
it he was uh I believe uh just looking
for this very nice Fork that he
completely missed that the queen can
capture the H5 Pawn uh because if you
capture on D4 now captures captures the
pawn is free and you you get rid of the
h on you don't have to worry about all
that much the bishop is now extremely
safe and Magnus would only be
up one Pawn in a very very tough
position to win but okay uh sorry about
that but okay after H5 we have knighted
the E4 uh going after this F6 pawn and
now Bishop to E7 but now it's much
different because after Knight captures
on D4 which was played in Queen captures
on D4 uh there is no Queen captures on
H5 now if Maxim goes for this Magnus
will just pick up the B2 pawn and the
past C Pawn now becomes too strong this
was impossible as long as the Knight was
on C3 but here Queen to E2 now comes
Pawn to F5 challenging the Knight Knight
to C3 and now Pawn to H4 challenging
this bishop and here Maxine played
Bishop captures on C7 which is a great
move uh but magnus's position is now
completely winning so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for Magnus
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not taking the
bishop and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show uh it is Queen to
G7 this is what Magnus played and he was
in this position on move 18 that Maxima
Shiela resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here of course
you can't capture the bishop because
that Knight the B5 check wins the queen
and then white is just completely
winning but after Queen to G7 there's no
defense Checkmate is being threatened
and also your Bishop is lost and even if
you play G3 black can even play H
captures on G3 uh and pick up the bishop
next and even if Bishop captures on G3
there's still F4 so there is no way uh
for for you to save this so of course
Maxim knew this and that's why he
resigned to the game now very nicely
done by Magnus for those of you who are
interested in the final standings these
are the standings so in five plus one uh
Magnus one uh six and a half to two and
a half then in three plus one Magnus one
five to four it was uh
a very very tough I think uh the first
like four or five games or maybe even
six games started with the draws before
Magnus uh uh won the won the first two
games and then the one plus one bullet
section ended by uh five and a half to
two and a half again Magnus winning
leaving the final score at 17 to nine so
that's uh absolutely incredible and we
all know what that means uh Morpheus is
fighting Neo uh Magnus will be facing
Hikaru Nakamura in the finals of the
speed chase championship and uh uh well
that's that's gonna be uh incredible to
watch I I'm looking very much forward to
it uh I think it's uh bad news for those
of you who are following the football
championship as it's the exact same time
uh as the world football championship
both of them start at 8 pm Central
European Time uh so you're gonna have to
you know or I mean you can watch both of
them simultaneously that's I mean what
uh normal people do uh but okay uh that
being said hope you guys enjoyed that as
well and uh you can see that Magnus said
I think none of us showed anything close
to our best level uh in the semi-finals
so whoever can step up for the final
will probably have a good chance of
saying that even though both he and
Hikaru pretty much completely crushed
their opponents uh it's not really the
best that they they have to offer so I
mean this is going to be an absolutely
incredible finals uh it's the one that
everyone's been uh waiting for uh so
let's let's all enjoy it uh that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank sapan Bhatia Sarah
Hamilton Jonathan Hiroshi quotes box and
governor of Bala for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on one of the
suggestions and of course covering the
finals of this uh spectacular event
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day